tell me do you like heavy spoilers
you won't have to this crap so the
snyder cut trailer
is online now and i thought i'd go
through it and just break down
everything that you need to know about
it there's a lot to talk about so yeah
let's just get straight into it
obviously heavy spoilers here we will be
talking about
big parts of the movie and leaks on
what's going to be happening in the
script so if you don't want anything
ruined
which i don't want to do i don't want to
ruin this for you then make sure you
turn off now
anyway thank you for clicking this sorry
i just found
one of my mum and dad's old masks so i
thought i'd put it on let's get into the
trailer anyway
but you don't really okay so at the
start there we saw
you axis who's a younger dark side hey
hate saying that word because i always
think i've pronounced it wrong
but yeah nice little start to it and
obviously superman dying at the end of
batman v superman there
really appreciated that opening and here
we have the justice league
hall and you've also got aquaman's
trident there
and this has been taken over by
darkseid's forces now obviously this is
the nightmare vision
so glad that this has been brought back
so that we can finally have some closure
on that thing that was in batman v
superman
when that happened a lot of people were
kind of like right well what does this
actually mean
really glad that they brought this back
it's basically what zack snyder was
gonna do was make a
five film arc which was man of steel uh
batman v superman justice league
and then justice league part two and
just to see part three
and in that they would go and fight the
forces of darkseid they would lose
uh this is what would happen the
nightmare vision would come true and
then flash would travel back in time and
change things
nice that they've stuck with it really
really appreciate this opening
and obviously hallelujah is playing as
well from watchmen a lot of people don't
like that scene in
the film but i i think it's all right
nice piece of music here
[Music]
okay and that's good that wonder woman's
actually went to find the spear because
in just the justice cut she just saw on
the news
this is a bit more dramatic and i will
say from the off
just the way this is shot it looks a lot
more engaging than the justice cut
just the way that everything sort of
pieced together the the way the camera
moves
zack snyder you know say what you like
about him
director wise just not around me but say
what you like about them
um as far as being a cinematographer
goes i think the guy
is near unmatched the way he puts images
together
the composition of them is absolutely
brilliant and it's great to see that in
effect
[Music]
and there's bruce wayne looking over a
hologram of superman obviously
this was in the original trailer that we
saw years and years ago
and he's just kind of formulating a plan
i think at this point they've lost
so he's really digging into it like he's
scanning superman's biometrics to see if
there's any way that they can revive him
and there's aquaman obviously he's just
dropped that guy off
he's taking his drink he saved his life
[Music]
and there's victor stone and playing for
the gotham rogues the gotham rogues are
obviously the football team in batman v
superman
what happens here is basically uh
victor's parents were meant to go to the
game to watch him play because it's
quite a big game for him
i've just realized how ridiculous i look
in this match mask
anyway go to go to the game see what's
happening
and victor wins he looks around to see
his mum and dad if they're cheering for
him just sees his mum
his dad's at the the lab building killer
robots again
luckily though it comes in handy which
we'll get into in just a bit so victor
basically has an argument with his
mother on the way home about
my dad's always at the lab building
killer robots and i never get to see him
victor's mom's like well you know we you
might need those killer robots
one day they crash the car his mother
dies
victor also dies but his dad resurrects
him in the form of cyborg
so there you go there's his brother
there
superman in the black suit yes
diana talking to the school kids that
she just saved and look at how good this
shot looks
you know you compare it with anything
from the justice league with the cgi
mustache which i should have shown up
rocking
much much better massive massive
improvement
[Music]
and there is flash of course saving iris
and i think this is how the two
actually meet um we did of course see
this in the trailer as well
and it's good to see it popping up back
here brilliant scene in which flash is
moving so
fast um basically the way flash moves
when he navigates the speed forces he
can also vibrate his body
so it is possible that if he touches
glass it vibrates and then shatters
good to see that here
[Music]
boom wouldn't be caught dead riding in
that
wouldn't be called dead smashing up
someone's grave now i'm guessing
that the way there's two gravestones
there
that might be spoiler alert his mother
and father
um his father does later get killed in
the
film by steppenwolf and he's obviously
taking it out on the grave
and you know what i've i've realized
this film we pretty much know most of
the plot for it and if there's still
spoiler ones this is how hyped
i am for this movie it wasn't much
that batman shot from the original
trailer that was of course change for
the justice cut
don't know why they changed it looks
much better
[Music]
and there is our martha
also the name of my mother um and lois
lane meeting so what's happened is
martha's been evicted
she's going to see lois lois is like get
your ass out of here
no she's not as aquaman's trident and
meeting with
amber hood
and there's you access again and it
looks like that's steppenwolf now what
happened was they obviously tried to
invade earth they were stopped by
uh the greek gods the forces of the
shazam wizards also apparently popped up
green lanterns
and steppenwolf went home defeated with
darkseid
he looks like he's sort of being outcast
here and his entire
motivation in the movie is to basically
win his
way back into apocalypse and he does he
looks really defeated yeah he looks a
bit like me with this stupid
i'm actually wearing a barber's cape
over my head now
so no expense spared
as cyborg um he's obviously dealing with
the fact that he's made from a mother
box
we do remember in the superman fight he
can't control his arm sometimes i can't
control my home you know what i'm saying
let's tell the wife that and here he's
clearly stuttering again
there's superman as he exits the thing
now what happens here
is basically batman didn't use lois lane
as a weapon
in in the original snyder cut in the
justice to cut
yeah she was there pulling out the big
guns
and what happened was she basically
visited heroes park every day
to see superman's grave and she was
passing again
and seen him in the air and that's why
she ran to heroes park
not because batman wanted to put her on
the front line
and now they're trying to crack the
mother box
and there's silas stone um he's
obviously been caught in the chamber
and this is when the character dies
unfortunately spoiler alert
i mean not really a spoiler because they
show them sort of getting doctor
manhattan out of there
so you know what take back the spoiler
warning
demascara and steppenwolf landing of
course
[Music]
much better design thousand times better
[Music]
and that looked like it was the speed
force there actually
split second
[Music]
yeah so you this is obviously when flash
goes to rescue
um his father and the captives i think
it is i'm saying obviously
not a clue uh but yeah you can see the
speed force demonstrated really well
here
[Music]
oh yeah excellent cut there
superman just punching steppenwolf i
like the way uh
you know what i did like in the justice
cut how superman just shows up in
clean's house
[Music]
[Applause]
batman's taking shots there so
he's his arm is very bulletproof because
he's getting shot several times there
damn uh and that is flash
i think they break the speed pause
[Music]
yeah this is a much more emotional scene
isn't it than what we got in the justice
cut that
that shot instantly looks better
[Music]
and that was when cyborg is basically
going through his programming to see
what he can do
he's sort of discovering his powers and
he realizes that
because of his abilities he has access
to all of the weapons on earth
and this is obviously a massive amount
of power for someone who's
just playing for gotham city university
sorry not
not the gotham rogues and he wipes it he
swipes it away though and it shows he's
got a good heart he's not out for power
that looked like it was the king of
atlantis and i'm guessing that's the
battle at the start we haven't
i don't remember seeing him in the fight
you know no he wasn't he wasn't he was
cut and then he popped up in aquaman so
yeah
great there that is cyborg saving mark
mcclure
who played jimmy olsen in the original
superman movie
and his cameo was changed for the
justice cut he became the security guard
at the prison that
flash when he was you know right in the
penny scribbled on that guy's face he
was the security guard then
originally though his cameo was to be a
policeman at heroes park
and he had a lot of interactions with
lois lane so that was obviously cut but
it's back
[Music]
and there's flash running through the
speed force and cracking the ground as
he runs
runs a bit funny though doesn't he
and there's the league amazing much
better
going home wow so it is going to be
called this night of course guys
probably fought hundreds of thousands of
other super beings on the other planets
he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
yes excellent excellent really hype with
that
um so hopefully yeah it looks like it's
gonna be amazing
obviously i'd love to hear your comments
so let me know if you like my mask
as well uh make sure you check out our
breakdowns from the rest of the day
we've got the
suicide squad trailer we've got the
wonder woman trailer
lots of stuff to talk about and the
batman trailer coming very soon
much love and thanks for sticking with
me cheers
you